[Music]
now we're back
uh I'm taking my car in
for servicing today I'm really excited
about that are you actually yeah there's
been like nine different warning lights
on my car that has just been there for
months you just looking the other way on
it yeah just a little blow up exactly
I'm in the middle of the highway I'm
Like Anything could happen right now the
wheels could just fall off
you know the car could just [ __ ]
explode the brakes could just like you
know it just stops driving like the
Wheels stopped moving in the middle of
the highway and we'd go ah yeah
out the front windshield are you nervous
about the results what they're gonna be
why I'm asking like like I'm doing
damage to my engine by not getting it
serviced no do you think it's like
severe
what all your warning lights
no I know what they are one of them is
um cool engine coolant is low and it's
been like that for a long time and I'm
like
I'm just hoping to God the engine
doesn't like
you know and I don't know get too hot
yeah yeah what hap what happens when the
coolant and how low can it go it's been
that for months it said coolant low dude
naturally your engine is getting hot no
I know it's so cool it is like kind of
important well that's why I'm getting it
fixed
are you you're probably low on oil too
no though I I haven't gotten the oil one
the oil one yeah no the oil light is
still yeah that one's fine oil white is
still good yeah the exploding one comes
up pretty often
I um I mean yeah no it's fine I mean
cool and low [ __ ] it
yeah [ __ ] it let someone else deal with
it yeah exactly that's why I'm just
really excited to have my car back and
have that feeling it's like it's all
good it's gonna be really funny when you
you go to pick it up and they're like
yeah so you've ruined your car yeah it's
permanent damage it's beyond repair
we're gonna have to put you into a VW
Bug
[ __ ] yeah I'll drive one of those oh I
got itchy ring finger oh no
it happens it's the old ball and turn
the old bag
so another thing is that you know I've
like tripled the amount of Miles I'm
supposed to put on my car yeah in my
lease so I'm gonna have to pay for that
at the end right yep yeah okay so that's
that's another thing I think my lease is
up in a year right how long have I had
my car for two years now yeah it's
typically three year cycle
has it been a year that I get a lot I
forget but anyways did you get it during
covid
yes most people got cars during covid
like right before the big like slow down
yeah so yeah you're you're at two years
coming up on three and uh another thing
car related actually that this that
you'll like to hear
is another sort of like little life hack
slapping on me that I've figured out you
know it's like
if you have the money for it and you
like to spend money on travel
something that you should do is rent a
car from turo oh yeah when you're in
whatever especially if it's a place like
Sonoma where it you know there's not
really Ubers or they're harder to get up
there and there's a lot of like open
wide roads rent a rent a car and like
normally when you rent a car it's from
you know whatever
you know Avis or whatever and you get
like a Yaris and it's not really you
gotta wait in line for hours and hours
it's not really a great experience
with turo it's this is not an ad for
turo or anything like that it's just
like I've figured this out now and I've
done it twice and it's just a really
good experience
I'll go on there even the date we uh the
day we were leaving I was like maybe I
should try and rent a car let's see what
they have on there
and there's a bunch of like Teslas and
whatever and I ended up renting a 2015
AMG
S63
[Music]
so what do you think of that
that's that's got some bark okay yeah
yeah it was fast but also like half
super fast half like super luxurious
massage seats yeah in the [ __ ] thing
oh yeah bro
and so we landed at SF SFO
and I told the guy my you know take a
time or whatever the uh frogging poor
people that's an airport code
yeah I mean people I think people know
SF airport okay okay I'm just laughing
at this conversation hey quick life hack
if you're ever in Sonoma
okay there's there's Dave onturo and he
rents out this 2015 S63 AMG and it is I
mean the massage seats and then only
it's only four grand a day to rent this
phone I'm kidding people are like damn
Cody you get enough massages in your
life
you need it in a car too
it's like yeah it's the best dude you
get a great nap yeah
[Music]
oh it's like first class in that thing
man you just take some pills yeah smash
a little champagne turn on the massage
stage do you just pass out you just wake
up to where you're supposed to go yeah
it has auto drive right full song I
don't think it does man no it's not epic
I got really lucky then
I were really lucky yes he liked what
color was it it was white big black rims
um just six or like no lines or anything
the guy pulls up outside of the it's his
car you know he's essentially just
renting it to me for three days he pulls
up outside of baggage claim we literally
walk out the door he hands us the keys
and we just have this sick car for three
days Joy yeah yeah and uh I really
enjoyed driving that car
you gotta you gotta you got a little bit
of itch for Driving Experience I mean I
like driving nice cars I'm just it's not
like a crazy passion of mine no no it
doesn't have to be like race cars yeah
yeah no I do like driving nice cars like
um
I enjoy
you know burning people off the line
yeah you know just a little jump yeah
that's the thing about my car is
I definitely I I get I arouse something
in the Tesla which which is the one
that's long
the model I don't even know the models
of Tesla yeah which is the one is it the
S the long one uh like the family wagon
yeah uh Model S I think I don't know
Model S owners in their mid-40s yeah
whenever I'm at a stoplight they just
they can't not like
like they see my car and it's like oh uh
I'm a [ __ ] yeah and so there's this
road by my place where
um
I'm in the middle Lane and I'm like Keen
to get to the left because the middle
and the right lanes
it's crazy in the span of they repaved
it maybe I don't know
six months ago and they did a shitty job
and there's like a it like goes over a
sewer line so there's like a natural dip
in the road
the time between the lazy repavement and
now it used to be like a little hump
dude now it's like a [ __ ] ramp okay
so I'm in the middle Lane and I kind of
slowly like
you know I get on the throttle a little
bit to get in front of the person to my
left
and Buddy in the Tesla I mean he was
just like
as soon as that light was green he's
like and he like mashes I'm like all
right bro it's such a funny thought you
like look kind of looking over and then
double taking because the guy's just
like yeah dude dude staring at you the
[ __ ] he's like what dude you know
so he like matches it
and then uh I kind of slowly get over to
the left
I'm laughing I'm like counting it down
I'm like five four three
all right dude it hit it pretty hard
like
he hit it pretty good and I'm laughing
like yeah dog like you know it's chill
out had another guy on the weekend
um now I'm actually remembering what I
did on the weekend
another dude same [ __ ] he's puffing a
cigar fat one windowed down
like I don't know kind of got like a mob
boss Vibe it's just he just
staring into my [ __ ] I'm like okay dude
here we go light goes green
I'm like have at it Tim no so I don't
know and do they bottom out or what no
this guy this was just this is a yeah no
I mean it you're not gonna beat an
electric car off the line yeah yeah you
know they they definitely get me on the
torque end for sure I'm gonna look sick
I think the Hummer it does yeah yeah it
looks really dope yeah
it's just so funny just polluting the
Earth
with battery production instead of gas
it's just the same [ __ ] yeah
I mean I wonder how many batteries it
takes I think EVS are like generally
better
uh but I want a truck next I think yeah
and that looks like sick I do too so I'm
with you let's go let's get matching
ones yeah
um
I just wonder what the capacity is on
this it would suck ass
to charge
yeah I bet you charging this is a [ __ ]
like cost wise or what no uh maybe maybe
the charging's efficient I just mean
like it's got to take a [ __ ] ton of
batteries yeah
it looks badass though I'm with you on
that
um but anyways yeah I was a little bit
of a car guy this week yeah no sorry
sorry I completely hijacked that no it's
fine that's that's all I had to say just
I just felt cool I don't know
like you know who inspired me to do that
is Josh Wiseman because he'll come into
town he'll rent a [ __ ] like McLaren
yeah
and it's like I don't really like you
know that's that's [ __ ] expensive but
still not as much as you would think
like he told me the price once and I was
like oh that's not I mean it's bad but
yeah I know what you mean yeah yeah you
would think it'd be way more yeah yeah
and I don't know I feel like I'm trying
to spend
a little bit less money recently so it
felt a little bit irresponsible but it
just made the trip so fun
you know
I mean it's like when I go to Hawaii
I'll ball out on the Jeep Rental yeah
I'll get the loudest ugliest one I
rented one that was like the same as
like the clout music video it was lime
green I was sick I drove it twice yeah
[ __ ] it I'm like just in case you know
it just if you go to downtown Lahaina
yeah yeah yeah dude and everyone
everyone does that there everyone it's
embarrassing it's so funny it's so
embarrassing no but it's like also like
a local thing to do deaf like loud ass
music people drive through downtown
Lahaina that's that's true that's very
true but I guess I feel
I look touristy like I feel like they
know yes of course [ __ ] tourists
yeah